recently i've come across this video by
our friends over at prageru entitled the
war on cars myself being european and
the major advocate for public transit
this naturally piqued my interest what
does prageru a terminally american
organization have to say about car
traffic there is a war against cars in
america regulators want americans out of
cars and onto trains buses and bicycles
why because of what cars represent
freedom and this type of content follows
a longer trend within prageru seems like
there's a war on everything nowadays the
war on work the war on boys the war on
christmas and now the war on cars
leftists are the real snowflakes by the
way so let's take a look at the war on
cars through the video they make seven
relevant arguments these are as follows
one cars are central to american culture
because they provide freedom 2 car
culture is dying because of government 3
government and environmentalists hate
personal freedom and want you out of the
car four instead of government enforcing
fuel efficiency it should have been left
up to the free market 5. urban planners
are building bike lanes reducing parking
spots and investing in public transit
and this is a bad thing 6. despite
government meddling low gas prices
encourage people to drive more and buy
bigger vehicles and this is a good thing
7. car ownership builds cohesion and
brings the country closer together
alright so these are prageru's main
arguments and coincidentally all of them
are horrendously stupid what's worse
they showcase a fundamental
misunderstanding of the concept of
freedom from prageru's part which is
kind of ironic so let's get right into
it shall we point number one cars are
central to american culture because they
provide freedom ever since henry ford
built the model t cars have been central
to the american experience that's
because cars are more than just another
way to get from point a
to point b
they allow us to go wherever we want
whenever we want with whomever we want
think about it with trains planes and
buses the routes are planned and the
schedule is timed
only cars allow you to be spontaneous
when you get behind the wheel you are in
control you are free
americans are explorers we value our
independence and we've never been good
at staying put or being told where to go
and at what time now referring to
culture is not a good argument there are
plenty of things that are part of
culture which aren't necessarily good
for example the taliban can say that
subjugating women is part of their
culture therefore they are opposed to
women's rights would anyone take an
argument like this seriously would
lauren here be okay with wearing a burqa
of course not just because something is
part of culture it doesn't make it
automatically good but of course the
real argument they are making here the
real problem this lady and prageru have
is that culture is changing core culture
seems to be on the way out in certain
areas of the us or at least it's
receding a little bit and conservatives
find this scary besides the only reason
cars became such an integral part of
american culture is because car
manufacturers successfully lobbied the
government in favor of their own
interests american cities were not built
for cars originally not even in the west
they did get demolished for cars though
where entire neighborhoods were
bulldozed to make way for urban freeways
which in the end flooded the inner
cities with cars which in turn
demolished further buildings to make way
for more lanes and more parking spaces
and this was of course a terrible
decision when it comes to livability
most u.s cities rank from lackluster to
just bad it's no coincidence that all of
the most livable cities on the planet
are oriented towards public transit and
pedestrians in fact i would call
obsession with course a cancer of
american culture one that makes life
objectively worse for people compared to
other countries let's move on to the
second point core culture is dying
because of government we may be
witnessing the death of america's car
culture
and it's not dying of old age
people are still buying lots of cars but
there's been a concerted push by
government bureaucrats and
environmentalists to transform car
ownership from a source of pride to a
source of guilt
now this kind of argumentation is of
course part of a wider prageru narrative
as in
one line government is not the solution
to our problems it is the problem but do
keep in mind that prageru's funding
comes in large part from fossil fuel
billionaires whose rational
self-interest dictates that they help
spread misinformation that can lead to
the loosening of government regulations
thus increasing their power and
consequently their wealth and this is
one of the reasons why i find prageru so
fascinating their audience anyway their
narrative is that a shadowy cabal of
leftists or jews depending on who you
ask are influencing the media and social
networks and academia you can't trust
anything coming from those sources but
prageru funded by fossil fuel
billionaires well that's where i get my
unbiased information from so is car
culture in the u.s dying because of
government
no in reality car use and car ownership
are on a downward trend in some places
in the u.s because a lot of people
realize that it's just not nice to live
in a congested city all the noise the
pollution the safety concerns all the
space that cars take up not to mention
the costs of having to maintain a car to
commute to work it's just not nice so
people don't do it if they don't have to
so let's move on to point number three
government and environmentalists hate
personal freedom and want you out of the
car the very reason people love cars
personal freedom
is also why regulators can't stand them
government at all levels craves control
and when it comes to your car they want
you off the road so are the
environmentalists with whom they have
made common cause now this ties heavily
into the previous point but i wanted to
address it separately because this point
showcases how prageru fundamentally
misunderstands the concept of personal
freedom which is you know pretty amazing
so let's perform a brief thought
experiment imagine that you are in the
desert there's nobody else around just
you that means nobody can tell you what
to do theoretically you are free to do
whatever you want you have absolute
freedom sounds good right in practice
however your freedom is severely limited
by your circumstances to the point where
the only thing you'll be able to do is
stumble around in the hot sand for a few
hours until you die of thirst and if you
live in an urban desert like an american
suburb if you want to get to work in the
morning theoretically you are free to
choose any transportation method that
you want which in this case aside from
cars is either walking or biking because
there's no public transit but in
practice you cannot take anything other
than your car because traffic makes
walking and biking incredibly dangerous
and it would take you three hours to get
to your workplace because turns out
freedom is not this monolithic thing
with an on off switch there are actually
two types of freedom prageru positive
and negative negative freedom is when
you are free from outside influences for
example when you are free from
government regulations free from having
to subsidize public transit through
taxation and so on positive freedom on
the other hand is when you are provided
with options from which you are free to
choose for example in europe due to the
excellent publicly funded infrastructure
i am free to decide how i want to get to
work do i want to cycle do i want to
take the bus do i want to take the train
in many cases i can even take my car to
work i mean it's possible but more
complicated and costly more on that
later in other words negative freedom is
freedom from something and positive
freedom is freedom for something and the
folks at prageru bless their hearts
regularly act like negative freedom is
the end-all be-all this is a fundamental
misunderstanding of freedom if you are
theoretically free to take any
transportation methods that you want but
in reality due to your circumstances you
can only take your car realistically
then you don't really have any freedom
do you and with that let's move on to
point number four instead of government
enforcing fuel efficiency it should be
left up to the free market this
antagonism toward america's car culture
can be traced back to the 1970s
in response to the arab oil embargo in
the early part of that decade congress
passed the national fuel economy
standards for cars and light trucks
these standards known as cafe short for
corporate average fuel economy forced
automakers to increase fuel efficiency
rather than let the free market decide
what kind of cars customers wanted to
buy the government decided to do the
dictating their regulations have cost
car companies and consumers many
billions of dollars but in the last
decade or so the government's heavy hand
has come down harder than ever
beginning in 2009 the obama
administration sought to dramatically
increase cafe requirements
these obama era standards make cars more
expensive
around four thousand dollars per new
vehicle according to economist saleem
firth and david kreutzer according to
economist celine firth and david
[Music]
[Music]
according to economist celine firth and
david pricer
now especially when it comes to the
environment letting the free market lose
usually makes things worse and to me the
fact that the pro-business center-right
obama administration had to intervene
and tighten fuel efficiency regulations
is proof in itself that it was justified
it means that the free market either
wouldn't solve the problem or would have
sold it way too slowly but in light of
the accelerating climate change we have
currently fuel efficiency is necessary
and the least we can do but of course in
the world of trigger prageru government
is not the solution to our problems it
is the problem point number five is that
urban planners are building bike lanes
reducing parking spots and investing in
public transit and this is a bad thing
still the regulators bureaucrats and
environmentalists persist
urban planners are adding bike lanes
reducing parking spots and pouring
billions into more public transportation
all to get people out of their cars
former boston mayor tom menino once
declared the car is no longer king
before banning all cars in a popular
downtown shopping district
arlington virginia a suburb of dc
actually encourages people to adopt a
car-free diet and live in one of the
county's urban villages
seattle meanwhile plans to aggressively
discourage driving by limiting parking
spots even though cars are an
unavoidable part of work and life for
most people according to the seattle
times
time will tell if these regulations and
strategies will work so as far as i'm
concerned this is just another episode
of conservatism versus reality i mean
how lost do you have to be to think that
these things are bad
once again the existence of europe
proves you wrong european cities built
out bike lanes reduced parking spots and
invested heavily in public transit and
they are objectively better for it they
are more livable but of course these
bigger utypes will not let facts
interfere with their thought process
it's the exact same story as with
universal healthcare oh you know that
would never work that's impossible you
know we can't simply fund a system like
that as the richest country on the
planet and then people point out that
every single european country has a
functioning universal healthcare system
that deliver objectively better results
than the us healthcare system for less
money and to that you usually get
responses like yeah well that's because
europe is white but the circle back to
breakery's point i have to ask why is
prageru so anti-small business small
businesses benefit from decongestion if
you take cars off a street and make it
more pleasant to walk and plan things
out correctly businesses on that street
will make more money and to quote this
study from 1993 titled impact of
pedestrianization and traffic calming on
retailing a review of evidence from
germany and the uk german has
implemented many ambitious
pedestrianization and traffic coming
schemes over the last 20 years and has
carried out quite large-scale research
studies on their effect on retailing the
schemes implemented in the uk and the
research carried out on them have been
more modest however they broadly show
the same picture there is generally a
positive effect on retailing with shops
inside pedestrian areas being more
successful than those outside and the
exact same trends seem to emerge in the
us especially during the covet epidemic
and its closures with places like little
italy and boston seeing a consumer
activity increase by as much as 61
if you want to learn more about the
economic effects of decongestion then
just google it and i don't know about
you but i'm frankly sick and tired of
these loud and aggressive minorities
coming in from a different area who take
over your neighborhoods and try to
dictate how you should live your life
that's right lady i'm talking about your
kind drivers how come these people who
don't even live there can barge into an
area and hog all the public spaces or
even have entire buildings demolished to
make way for parking lots and if you
dare bringing this up to them they get
all triggered and start screaming at you
about how you're communist and hate
america and freedom a bunch of
snowflakes and so point number six on
breaker use big brain list despite
government meddling low gas prices
encourage people to drive more and buy
bigger vehicles and this is a good thing
maybe that's why despite the
government's best laid plans sales of
trucks and suvs are breaking records as
low gasoline prices inspire people to
drive more and buy bigger vehicles
why shouldn't they so i've looked up
fuel prices and holy [ __ ] gas costs
almost half as much in the u.s compared
to germany where i live according to
this quartz article this ends up to
americans paying the second lowest price
for gasoline among major world economies
and why is that is it because of the
free markets brilliant innovations
bringing us low prices
of course not it's because of billions
of dollars of subsidies to the oil
sector and wow if you think about it
what a historic event this is
conservatives wanting to subsidize
something that's black but the problem
is that these subsidies produce this
vicious circle type situation if you're
subsidizing fuel prices the economy will
be more and more dependent on cars and
that means you have to keep pumping
those subsidies because if you stop you
risk causing an economic collapse in
other words through some divine irony
all these freedom shouting core centric
conservatives are welfare queens with
the taxpayers subsidizing their
lifestyles and how nice is that and so
prageru's seventh point is car ownership
builds cohesion and brings the country
closer together personal car ownership
is part of america's fabric it brings
people together and makes this big
country of ours seem a little smaller
and more free
america's car culture isn't dead
yet
so as long as americans still want to
live in the land of the free america's
car culture will never die and here i'd
like to recommend a video from the
youtube user not just bikes titled why
we won't raise our kids in suburbia and
moved to the netherlands instead it's
some great content describing how car
centric areas propagate the atomization
of society which is the opposite of
bringing people together i don't want to
belabor this point too much because you
can just go and watch the video it's
great but i'll say this much car-centric
areas are generally not dense people are
spread thin and there's nothing you can
do locally really you have to go to the
nearest strip mall which is 15 minutes
away by car and even there there isn't
really any community space you know
there's just a big parking lot and some
stores in a european settlement on the
other hand the place has a definite
center a place to go a place to hang out
a place that is reachable by bike or on
foot because everything is close by
because the settlement is compact
because it wasn't built around cars in a
place like this on the other hand in
american suburb where do you hang out
where do you go yeah would you like to
go and hang out on this nondescript
street or that one hey let's check out
that dead patch of grass in the upper
left corner or do you prefer to stand
next to the arterial road instead these
areas do everything but bring people
closer together the atomized society in
areas like this you either stay home or
go somewhere else to do things if you
want to build cohesion and bring people
closer together car centric areas are
the exact opposite of what you need we
need human-centric walkable settlements
and we need them now and no there is no
war on cars in the us but i wish it was
american cities would objectively be
better for it
thank you for watching and yeah prageru
is still pretty dumb please don't forget
to like and subscribe check out my
patreon and i'll be seeing you next time
genocide's our solution to our problems